ثلاثيه قاضيه تلقاها الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب في الايام الاخيره
فتراب غارق في كومه من المشاكل بعد تلقيه
ثلاثه اخبار سيئه بوقت واحد بشان لوائح
اتهام ومحاكمه جنائيه محتمله في نيويورك
وجورجيا مجله نيوزويك اكدت ان الرئيس
الامريكي السابق يواجه هجوما قضائيا
متصاعدا ما قد يجعل من هذا العام
عامه فالمدعي العام لمقاطعه منعه يستعد
لتوجيه الاتهام للتراب بشان اموال دفعها
لممثله اباحيه عام 2016 مع توقعات باعتقال
ترامب كما رفض قادم تاجيل موعد محاكمه
ثانيه في من اكتوبر طبعا في قضيه احتيال
مدني منفصله رفعتها المدعيه العامه في
نيويورك ضد ترامب وثلاثه من ابنائه اما
شبكه سي ان ان فرجحت توجيه المدعي العامه
لمقاطعه
بولايه جورجيا تهم ابتزاز وتامر لترامب
على خلفيه جهوده لالغاء نتائج الانتخابات
الرئاسيه لعام 2020 في جورجيا تحديدا
ترامب الذي اعلن عن ترشحه الانتخابات
المقبله ينفي ارتكاب اي مخالفات ويصف هذه
الادعاءات بانها جزء من مطارده سياسيه من
قبل طبعا خصومه الديمقراطي
[موسيقى]